revenir bien sûr sur l'allocution
d'emmanuel bacon c'était il y à quelques
minutes qu at il annoncé
emmanuel macron il annoncé un
renforcement des dispositifs déjà mis en
place puisqu'il a élargi à tout le
territoire
les mesures déjà prises dans 19
départements voilà donc on fait
couvre-feu à 19h et fermeture de tous
les to les lélés commerce mène entendu
et surtout ce qu'il a annoncé fermeture
des écoles pour quatre semaines
dès vendredi donc ce qu'on avait un
petit peu près 10 s'est passé c'est à
dire que eelv a avancé les vacances de
pâques pour que tous les enfants
puissent rester pendant quatre semaines
voilà chez eux et peut-être que ce
serait l'occasion bien sûr de vacciner
les enseignants pendant ce laps de temps
sait on est on l'évoquait hier avec vous
docteur ramon est ce que vous avez été
le combat qu est ce que vous attendiez
vous trouvez que c'est des bonnes
mesures
il fallait prendre il fallait prendre
des mesures pour freiner virus
c'est sûr que bon ces mesures la ccpo le
confinement sévère que réclamait pas mal
de médecins mais en même temps je pense
sincèrement que ce sont des mesures
raisonnables qui sont acceptables par
l'ensemble de la population il va y
avoir du monde sur les routes vendredi
exactement alors justement mode brégeon
on a eu la sensation et moi je l'avais
dit si les uns ou le rappelez vous
j'avais dit emmanuel macron ne fera pas
un confinement général il est sur sa
ligne et il reste sur sa ligne et mine
de rien ils ne prononcent très peu le
mot confinement dans le bourg ce pas
d'ailleurs le mot confinement et dix et
un couvre-feu à 19 heures c'est des
aménagements il reste sur sa ligne et et
l'espère comme on désire que la courbe
voilà 10 ans se stabilise et qu'avec les
vacances et les écoles qui ferment un
petit peu plus tôt il va pouvoir s'en
sortir et il a dit tout de suite le
premier truc qu'il a dit est très vite
dans son allocution s'est regardé les
autres pays ont confiné pas nous mène
donc ils espèrent peut-être
politiquement dire dont 3 4 semaines un
mois et demi regardez on est le seul
pays à ne pas d'avoir confiné et on est
sortis de là donc peut-être que pour lui
ce serait une victoire donc c'était sûr
qu'il avait pas confiné en fait quand tu
regarde ce qui s'est passé en allemagne
ils ont confiné à trois mois et ils sont
encore confiné nous c'est autant de
semaines qu'on a à gagner pour les
commerçants pour les écoles voilà tout
ça on s'en rend compte que confiné
c'est pas une fin en soi c'est là ce
qu'on fait c'est une course contre la
montre c'est à dire qu il ya des mesures
supplémentaires parce qu'on va pas se
mentir la pression hospitalière elle est
extrêmement forte et en même temps on
vacciner massivement il y aura dix
millions de personnes lit mais 20
millions de personnes vivent un million
de personnes me met 30 millions de
personnes mi juin
et c'est comme ça qu'on va en sortir et
puis le dernier point que t'as pas
évoqué c'est que le président n'a
appliqué il a aussi donné des
perspectives aux français est latent
parlera mieux que moi alors justement
c'est quoi les perspectives et ses 5
avril déjà une semaine c'est dans la
maison pour les écoles collèges et
lycées n'ont pas ses perspectives là ce
sont les annoncer à partir de mi-mai il
a annoncé le calendrier oui retrouver
une vie un peu plus normale et tu en
parles et notamment pour les commerçants
pour vous c'est au c'est à dire côté
continue miami ont été diminués une vie
presque normale ça concerne également
les restaurants une vie plus normale ou
petit à petit à petit on va avoir freiné
le virus grâce aux restrictions
nouvelles qu'on a imposé et grâce à la
vaccination qui va continuer à se
déployer
eh bien on le voit c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans d'autres pays d'ailleurs
petit à petit de façon mesurée de façon
raisonnable
on va pouvoir desserrer les contraintes
et c'était important aussi je pense que
le président de la république
il donne de la perspective parce qu'on a
aussi besoin de pouvoir se projeter mais
particulièrement je pense à vous alors
c'était pas de manigold ça vous a fait
ou ce qu'il a dit le chef de l'état
ça vous donne de l'espoir parce que ce
que vient de dire modèle dit que me mais
peut-être qu'on pourrait rouvrir les
terrasses etc bon je pense d'eux bon
haut-parleurs bernard montiel qui a
poussé sur les terrasses et cyril ici en
la demande et oui c'est efficace
on est convaincu en tout cas par le
calendrier par contre qu'on a absolument
pas convaincu et disons le quand même
c'est la politique de vaccination
d'olive et veyran là on n'y est pas j'ai
eu un maire d'arrondissement tout à
l'heure au téléphone de paris semaine
prochaine il y à 25% de vaccins au moins
pour paris et sa vraie catastrophe
donc moi le programme là qui est annoncé
je le signe honnêtement mais vers en
faut qu'il faut qu'ils se mettent une
charge mais alors on adore un différend
m
non mais le fait que aujourd'hui les
usines avaient du mal à produire en tout
cas en quantité suffisante pour le monde
entier
c'est pas un problème je veux vous dire
il ya un problème de communication
oliveira ça a l'air d'être un garçon
très sympathique mais quand vous avez un
garçon qui a d'autres temps ce qui viens
vous parler c'est pas possible on n'y
croit pas un instant je vous dis la
vérité lui sauter dessus du supra dit
non mais ce cas du président ce soir
c'est que il tiendra sa promesse c'est à
dire que d'ici à l'été tous les français
depuis 18 ans qui le souhaitent auront
accès au vaccin mais on veut tous ses
pôles y verront entre nous stéphane
c'est le chef de l'état qui gère ça
olivier ferrand où il gère avec les
contraintes qui souhaitent une industrie
qui produit des vaccins pour le monde
entier c'est leur droit mais c'est pas
olivier béland qui valait négocier des
contrats alors si c'est olivier ferrand
qui va négocier des concours faire c'est
à dire que les vaccins les vaccins tu
les hauts rangs de nombreux tweets frère
le temps qu'ils se réveillent juste on a
vu aussi
moi ce que j'ai senti de la part du chef
de l'état c'est aussi de dire on va
prendre ces mesures qui sont les mesures
il ne rien les n'ai plus cessé et moins
restrictive
parce qu'on s'attendait ap à bien pire
mais il a dit aux français prenez vos
responsabilités
c'est ça qui le radiant il aura dirigé
vous laisser pas mal de liberté ya plein
de gens là qui réagissent qui disent ah
ben là on peut partir en vacances on
peut se déplacer ça va être la folie là
pendant les vacances de pâques et c'est
ce qui fait le plus réagir certaines ce
qu'il a dit là des prenez vos
responsabilités est ce que ça vous plaît
ça j'en lis ya le fait qu'on
responsabilise les français s'est jamais
une mauvaise chose puisqu'on les
infantiliser depuis un an maintenant et
ça peut trouver bon là il ya pas mal de
gens je vous le dis mais je vais vous
savez je suis pas voilà je suis assez
impartiale et voilà je le dis hein
il ya beaucoup de gens qui l'ont trouvé
bon ce soir jeudi d'abord il a annoncé
très peu de choses finalement quand on
quand on réfléchit par rapport à la
situation dans la rue cela j'ai déjà
match aux livres interdits est à partir
de 5 avril c'était pas la joie
il a parlé d'une taille c'est à dire la
vaccination et l'augmentation
capacitaire des réanimations alors il
nous dit emmanuel macron qui voit la
lumière au bout du tunnel moi je vois
pas comment il fait pour la boire avant
qu'elle ait des lunettes de vision
nocturne je vois pas où ils voient la
lumière dans la situation actuelle
d'autant plus qu effectivement à la fois
en termes de vaccins et en terme
animations pour l'instant le gouvernant
a raconté que des cracks dominé de joris
jusqu'au idrac ligue au mans temps il
faudrait qu'ils aillent chercher des
boulettes chez ma mère sans rigoler
c'est pas une vanne mais personne n'est
venu chercher ton repas voilà donc je le
dis c'est pas donc je disais que pour
l'instant marc emmanuel macron et
olivier ferrand ne sont pas aux
commandes en matière d'approvisionnement
des vaccins puisque c'est l'union
européenne qui livrent donc ils sont
tributaires de ça donc toutes les
promesses qu'ils nous font en fait non
gage que ceux qui les entendent
c'est-à-dire eux-mêmes mais vous n'y
croyez pas ce type de soirées ou des
moins quand on m'a annoncé 12 mille lits
en août 2020 au cas où ça où les choses
tournent au vinaigre et qu'elles sont en
train de tourner au vinaigre et qu'on
n'a pas vu le début du commencement du
moindre lits supplémentaires
permettez moi de ne pas croire en ça je
veux dire le mans le gouvernement n'a
fait que mentir surtout depuis le début
il s'est décrédibilisé en même temps
qu'il à décrédibiliser la parole
publique donc moi si vous voulez moi
j'aimerais bien croire à sa meilleure
d'ailleurs à trois mois moi je vais vous
dire moi ce que j'ai aimé et je dis
ouais c'est qu'on a un calendrier après
mois et nous et nous moi et et
l'ensemble des français qui nous
regardent ils ont envie de le croire
mais c'est michel c'est ce qu'a dit
stéphane le pitbull syrien d'un
calendrier on veut savoir où on va c'est
on va après les limites alors le
calendrier il avait quand même annoncé
initialement qu'au 15 avril on
commencerait à ré ouvrir progressivement
on s'aperçoit qu'aucun a droit aussi je
vous accordez vous à 85,20 de réfléchir
à aarau confiné donc moi si vous les
jeux je trouve tout ça donne
il a d'ailleurs lui-même sans la perçois
pas ce qu'il dit à un moment il faut
revenir à une stratégie nationale il
faut produire les vaccins nationalement
lui même reconnaît entre les lignes
effectivement que la stratégie euro 6
qui l'a évincé européiste vaccinale
qu'on a adopté depuis un an est un échec
cuisant et ne reconnaît plus la base est
remarquable à chier avons pas moi je
t'ai globalement d'accord avec ce qui
était annoncé je pense que cette
fermeture d'une semaine des écoles était
pas nécessaire et aura un effet été
démis que très limitée en revanche je
pense qu'il se fait d'illusions s'ils
pensent qu'il va pouvoir ré ouvrir mais
me mais sans avoir une stratégie basée
sur des autotests fait que les gens
seront négatifs en est il arrivé cyr et
s'il le faisait il pourrait même rouvrir
avant mais on veut aux etats unis ils
ont vacciner massivement et l'épidémie
repas on ne peut pas rouvrir si
facilement qu'on avait actionné il faut
absolument une partie des vaccins et
l'autre partie cette espèce de
passeports antigénique qui fait ça va
pouvoir faire des choses en se testant
de façon négative
olivier
on ne fait rien sur le sujet s'il avait
une seule chose à faire parce que les
vaccins c'est pas lui c'est l'europe
c'est s'occuper de cette question des
autotests et la réouverture avec ses
stratégies je sais pas pourquoi il le
fait pas je pense que s'il ya une chose
qui devrait faire c'est ça et s'est pas
fait donc c'est les lits en réanimation
et cette stratégie d'autotest je vous
encourage vraiment travailler sur ce
sujet parce que la drogue était s'il ne
fait pas aujourd'hui lui alors vous vous
dites que sur la fermeture des écoles là
une semaine avant vous n'êtes pas pour
les maternelles les écoles les collèges
et des lycées fermés pendant trois
semaines est ce que vous auriez pris la
même mesure
dr hamon moi je pense que c'était une
mesure raisonnable il est en train de
calculer il est en train de faire le
calcul c'est tout à fait raisonnable
dans la mesure où ça va freiner un tout
petit poil ça va freiner à tous qui est
sale on est à cinq mules et de
réanimation
on était à 7500 quand même à la première
vague d'achat sur 1 donc on a encore un
peu de marge avant d'arriver au 7500
c'est parce qu'il faut souhaiter mais
c'est même si ça freine après on va
quand même arrivé à l'été est là je
lâche là je parle au citoyen et je parle
à stéphane vinet h par la mode je pars à
tous les gens voilà qui sont ici bien
sûr tous les tous les chroniqueurs pour
emmanuel macron ci réussit son coup de
fer se mit confinement me couvre feu
qu'ils arrivent à s'en sortir
nîmes et famé et qu'en juin tout repart
est ce que pour lui ce serait une grande
victoire et une grosse victoire
politique
celle dernière survie ont
indiscutablement s'il y arrive
s'il y arrive bien sûr parce qu'il aura
évité le confinement brutal mais
justement est ce que c est ce que ces
décisions ne sont pas guidés que par
cette envie se dire j'étais le seul à ne
pas confiné et que mine de rien il
n'écoute pas beaucoup les les
scientifiques c'est aussi ce que pense
qu'elle est quand même c'est bien beau
de dire me mets peut-être une vie
normale mais encore une fois c'est un
voeu pieux et moi j'ai l'impression
qu'on recule de quelques semaines mais
que cette stratégie elle n'est quand
même pas arrimé sur des certitudes
scientifiques et que le président fait
de la politique mais je ne suis pas très
sûr madame que tout ça va être efficace
c'est complètement l'inversé el achkar
votre contrôle à vous deux mais
aujourd'hui les mesures qui sont mises
en place
elles sont basées sur les connaissances
scientifiques à date par exemple on sait
les scientifiques savent et les mets
saint à ma gauche ça que plus de 90% des
contaminations son intérieur en
intérieur donc en fait adapté l'eau
confiant de finir et ça on ne sort pas
il ya un an
mais aujourd'hui ça on le sait donc dire
aux gens bah oui en fait vous avez le
droit de vous balader et vous avez le
droit de vous balader plus d'une heure
parce qu'aujourd'hui on sait que sous
réserve évidemment du respect des gestes
barrières et en portant un masque vous
risquez beaucoup moins à l'extérieur
s'est basé sur des connaissances
scientifiques
et puis il ya une dernier un dernier
point quand même c'est que dans ces
décisions là douze mois après le début
de la crise il ya un équilibre à trouver
quand même de l'état entre le sanitaire
et c'est pour ça que de nouvelles
décisions ont été prises l'économie
parce qu'il ya des emplois derrière il
ya des restaurateurs il ya des problèmes
que j'ai monté psycho le problème
problème que j'évoque aussi fatigué le
problème